Take a walk down memory lane.
Excuse the mess.
MIKE WOLFE: Oh, this
isn't messy for us.
FRANK FRITZ: Uh-uh.
- These are what I really like.
- Do you?
- Oh, yeah.
This is the largest collection
of Marx toys on display
anywhere in the world.
Collecting toys is a fever.
I hope there's no cure.
MIKE WOLFE: There's, like,
so much stuff to see in here.
I love it.
You know you're
getting older when
the toys that you
played with as a kid
are now considered antiques.
So Francis, is everything
I'm looking at here for sale?
A lot of stuff is for sale.
Here's a really nice toy.
This one was made
in Great Britain.
You don't see too many march
toys made in Great Britain.
FRANK FRITZ: A lot of these
toys I've had, or still have.
But the Goofy toy--
I don't have this one.
Missing one ear, though.
FRANK FRITZ: It is
missing one ear.
But the ears are
made out of rubber.
You can make them
and put it back in.
Or you can just leave
it the way it is.
Does it work?
Oh, oh, oh.
It's kind of a funny toy
with his legs going everywhere.
FRANK FRITZ: That is so cool.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep,
beep, beep, beep, beep, beep,
beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Kind of reminds
me of my wife going
around in circles all the time.
FRANK FRITZ: [laughs] Is this
something you would sell?
Yeah, I would sell--
$475.
It's in great condition.
And what the seller is is
when Frances bombed it up
and it did the full circle
right in front of me.
He had me at the first lap.
How about $450?
$450?
- We're so close.
- So close.
I can do it.
- $450?
- $450.
- All right.
It's not scuffed up.
It's in great condition.
It works.
I think it's worth
at least $700.
What about the Buck Rogers one?
Buck Rogers was a pulp
fiction hero from the 1920s
that traveled through space.
He started out in books.
Then he went to comic strips,
then he went to the radio,
then he went to
television and video.
He's been around
for generations.
So naturally, Marx licensed
the character to make toys.
What I liked about
these is, you know,
they have flints inside of them.
And what would happen is
when you wound them up,
it would have shot
sparks out the back.
Flint would come out
and take your nog off.
Something like that.
Yeah, I don't need the thing
hitting me in the eyes.
Kids toys today are digital.
Whatever they're doing,
they're not actually doing
it, because it's on a screen.
These toys are cool because you
had to have an imagination--
flying that through
the air, you know,
winding it up, seeing
the sparks shoot out.
That was a big deal back then.
[toys clatter]
- Ah, hear that?
- I know.
That's good.
I like that.
I like that sound.
FRANCIS TURNER: Very
high quality toys.
They still run,
just like they did
back then when they made them.
These toys are going to be
running 60, 80 years from now.
FRANK FRITZ: Which one is rarer?
I would think this
would be the earlier one.
FRANK FRITZ: Now, both of them
have some condition problems,
but they're still
very collectible.
One's made in the '30s,
one's made in the early '40s.
Just to see a toy
that's 80 years
old, that it still exists--
these are the kind of toys
you just can't find anymore.
What would you have
to have on this one?
This one's a little--
it's got a little
damage on it here.
It's been played with
on here, you know.
- Yeah. $450.
- $450.
What would you do if
I bought both of them?
$900?
Ooh, that's not two--
that's still another $450.
I mean, if they were
mint in the box--
yeah, then we'd be
talking $500, $600.
But the way the
condition they are,
I've got to get them
for a cheaper price.
Let's do like $650 or so.
- $650?
Yeah.
No, no.
We couldn't do $650.
How about $700?
MIKE WOLFE: When
you're very little,
you want to show off your toys.
You bring them over to
your friend's house,
and you guys play with
each other's toys.
And you might even
do some trading.
And that's where
you learn to deal.
$775-- they're yours.
$725.
So when Francis and
Frank are going at it--
$750.
It just reminded me of that.
- $735.
- OK.
- All right.
- I'll do it.
OK.
It was awesome to see
little Frankie in his element
with Francis.
Francis, what can you tell
me about the Charlie McCarthy?
This reminds me of
my first girlfriend.
FRANK FRITZ: It's a nice
example of a Marx toy.
How about $100 and a half?
FRANCIS TURNER: I can do it.
All right, you got it.
What can we do on the car here?
It's in really
great condition.
It works.
When the bumper hits on
the front, the heads pop up.
How about $1,200?
Make it $1,250 and it's yours.
I mean, I don't come
across this stuff.
I think I can get $1,500
to maybe $1,800 out of it
to the right guy.
And now, these toys
you've got here--
these are the same concept
as Charles McCarthy.
- Yeah.
- It has the same motor.
Probably the same guy cast the
same stamping and everything.
It's just with different
comic characters.
What would you have to have
for these three characters?
You have B.O. Plenty,
which came from Dick Tracy.
FRANCIS TURNER: With a nose like
that, that has to be Pinocchio.
That's no lie.
Then you have Dopey,
one of the seven dwarfs.
Like, I could do
maybe $675, and I
think that would be the best.
You got a deal.
This place is getting
me junk drunk.